Ah, okay, there we go.
Sorry, because I unplugged my stuff.
I had to reset it back up.
Dang it, you guys missed my really awesome intro.
Should I try it again?
Should I do it again?
Yeah?
Okay, hold on...
I just wanna be part of your symphony!
That's it, that's the intro.
That's the intro.
Oh my gosh, you guys!
I'm so...
I'm so tired.
I'm so sleepy.
I have a green smoothie here.
I have vitamin water.
And I ate two eggs.
The two eggs were my dinner.
I'm looking at my bed and I'm just like oh my gosh it looks so comfy.
What about coffee?
It's like almost 11 p.m.
I don't want to have coffee.
I gotta wake up and stream.
So I have to sleep enough.
You know?
To then stream and be with energy in the morning.
What's so different from the overnight drive back from AMIC?
I missed yesterday's stream.
What would A++++ plus would A++++ would hamtaro circle again.
Thank you.
I'm so tired.
Oh my gosh.
Take care Minto.
Thank you.
You're welcome Minto.
Thanks.
Oh I forgot to take my medicine.
So if you ever get medicine in Japan it's you know you always hear how, your medicine and tablet medicine in Japan is not as strong right?
But they they make you take a lot of it.
Like like I have this medicine they recommend you to take it take three pills.
Three times a day!
That's nine pills a day!
That's insane!
You guys were just crazy at the three.
Three?
No, no.
It's three pills, three times a day!
I only took some this morning and I'm starting to like...
I'm weaning off the meds, you guys.
My waifu will come back.
She's gonna come back, you guys.
I can already see her arm phasing in.
Because I'm only taking it two times a day instead of three.
But we're doing the... that was one pill.
We're doing the Nintendo Partner Showcase.
I never... I never see when Nintendo Directs are.
So... thanks for everybody who tells me when these things are.
Because otherwise... that's why they're always like last minute.
Because I'm like, oh, there's a Direct?
Okay.
But I think it's the Indie one first and then...
Are you screening the vid?
Yeah.
I have it on behind me.
I'll move my big head once it's time to start.
Don't worry.
Crazy they're all suppository.
No, they're not.
I didn't say it.
I literally just swallowed it right now!
Shut the heck up!
Did you see IGN said MGS Delta is not great because it's so faithful and not modernized.
Oh my gosh.
I saw... I did not read their...
I did not read... whatever they said or watch whatever they said.
But I heard about it.
Which is just so...
What?
Wow.
My Metal Gear Solid 3 game is too much like Metal Gear Solid 3.
What an L.
They complain about the loading screens.
Okay.
Sure.
Whatever.
We'll see.
Speaking of Metal Gear...
I don't know if they want to say it or if they want me to say it or what.
I have to probably move Holocure a little bit for the times.
Push it back.
I don't know.
Maybe an hour or two.
Because...
Because I have some other stuff on Thursday that I forgot to put on my calendar.
Remember the too much water review.
I don't know why you guys are getting so worked up.
It's not anything so... you know.
I don't know what you're expecting.
Can I have a drink?
Um...
Is this where I put the money to make sure Silksong is in the direct?
Yeah.
Just send it over.
I'll take it.
Yeah, yeah.
Just send it over.
To me.
You know.
And I'll take it.
No worries.
I got it.
Thank you.
Okay.
For...
I don't even know what to expect for this though.
Because it's all partner stuff.
It could be anything.
Who knows?
Everybody wants Silksong.
I'm here for Ace Combat.
Yeah, I want to see the stuff about Ace Combat.
If they say anything.
Of course you're here, Nan, for Ace Combat.
I still can't believe you have the power to make people run in a circle.
Hamtaro's theme is still stuck in my head.
I was singing it earlier too, I'll be honest.
Along with, I just wanna be part of your symphony.
This combat is not Switch focused.
What are you talking about?
It's literally coming out on the Switch.
They just announced it.
Like, not even that long ago.
So they could, you know, talk about it here.
You know?
New Ace Attorney?
Oh my gosh.
I would... I would cry.
Cry for new Ace Attorney.
Though I'm one game behind.
Well, technically.
But they announced the Edgeworth stuff last time.
Which was very exciting.
I yelled.
Oh, it's already out for the Switch.
Sorry, I'm so tired of guys.
Return of Godot.
I thought, I'll be honest, I thought about that.
I was like, they're gonna add him back.
They're gonna bring him back.
They're gonna resurrect him.
Please.
Maybe the stream was a mistake.
Oh gosh.
Maybe I should have just said, sorry guys.
My eyelids are too heavy.
Is that my phone?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
Trusting you with my Silksong money.
Everybody place your Silksong bets here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hello.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Jump scare.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Thank you.
First up, here's the Indie World Showcase.
Okay, first Indies.
Oh no.
Okay, please not be so long.
I'm so tired.
I'm also indie.
This is my showcase, you guys.
Beep boop bop, beep beep boop.
Beep beep boop, beep boop.
Oh, can you guys...
Oh, sorry.
I just realized I shrugged the screen.
Sorry, guys.
Sorry.
I'm Amber.
And I'm Andrew.
We're back with more indie games headed to the Nintendo Switch system.
All right.
It's time to lay our cards on the table.
Sure thing.
Can you guys hear it?
Why is there a joker in my hand?
Here's the deal.
Wait.
Blackjack?
Black hole.
Close enough.
Hahaha.
I hate portals.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Not the Baltaro.
Bal...
Baldi's Basics?
Balotrol.
Bal...
Balbo.
Wait.
With vampire survivors?
Yo.
Everything is vampire survivors.
Wow.
Oh, my God.
The cards.
With the banana.
This is too much, man.
Make it end.
What was the first one?
I didn't catch it.
It was something in the vampire survivors.
What was the first one?
Oh.
So, no.
That's choreography.
I know.
It was a joke.
Oh, Witcher.
Okay, thank you.
That means we can have...
We can have a ball of...
A Bolognese with crossover Metal Gear.
It can happen, you guys.
That way I'll play the game.
Hahaha.
I was...
A game called...
Ball.
Steel ball run.
Steel...
Oh.
Balotrol.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
Oh.
Wow.
Wait.
We've seen this before, right?
I remember that scene with the wolf in the beginning and stuff.
I feel like we saw this before.
Or not the wolf, whatever that... yeah, that thing.
The dog.
It looks really nice, though.
October 15th!
Oh, that's recent.
Never.
It looks so good.
This is like everything I hate.
My office job, Matara-Kan.
Why is it Undertale all of a sudden?
I like the butterflies.
Cute.
Moths?
What is going on?
What?
Moths.
The moth was watching Naruto!
Moth-suto.
Hello.
Hi.
Why are the other people frozen?
Free them!
Is this not a Zoom call?
Oh, God.
I'm Amanda Winterstein, a game designer and a writer.
There are OLPTSD kicking in.
As soon as they said climb up the corporate ladder, I'm just like, oh.
A writer and an English to Japanese games translator.
I had the privilege to work on the Japanese translations of both Coffee Talk games.
Today, we are thrilled to announce that we are partnering with Chorus to expand the Coffee Talk world.
We've been hard at work over the last year to come up with a story that retains the cozy elements Coffee Talk 5 has.
You thought I was a game dev, but I'm Dio.
Zawardo!
And now, we're very proud to announce an exciting new game for Coffee Talk fans.
Coffee Talk Tokyo!
Oh!
Coffee Talk Tokyo?
Oh...
This...
Oh, no.
Oh...
The music is so good.
Oh, my God.
What the hell is this weeb?
No, I'm gonna have to play this.
Oh, my gosh.
You can...
Oh, my God.
What?
It feels so good.
I would put on...
When I was in my last hotel, I would put on, like, lo-fi and jazz and just stare out the window while sipping on coffee in the night.
I felt like royalty, you guys.
I was like, I've never stayed in such a fancy hotel.
Sakana has, like, insane expensive taste.
Oh!
Hendry!
You're looking a little hen-dry, though.
What kind of name is that?
Let's check out some upcoming downloadable content that will take you to new and unexpected places.
So aesthetic, Minto.
Oh.
Discover a miniature clockwork world in the Sea of Stars Throes of the Watchmaker DLC.
Gear up for a journey full of oddities and wonders in which Valir and Xael will have to play by new rules to put a stop to a cursed carnival.
Oh, I like carnival.
Xael will transform into a skillful juggler.
This feels very...
While Valir will dazzle as an acrobat.
Like Square Enix games and all.
Together with new playable character Arty, they'll explore new areas and battle through dangerous dungeons in their quest to save the world of Orlige.
A malevolent spectacle awaits when this free DLC for Sea of Stars launches on Nintendo Switch next spring.
It's inspired by Chrono Trigger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see it, I see it, I see it.
Hey!
Get out of my swamp!
Shrek?
Sorry, Ember.
No.
This swamp has layers of dirt.
Shut up.
The Direct was worth it.
Fine.
I'm over it anyway.
A muddy good time awaits in the Shrek Special Pack paid DLC for Power Watch Simulator.
Oh, the Direct was so worth.
Fear is all-star as you wash away the grime covering five fairy tale maps from the Shrek universe, including Shrek's very own swamp and the Dragon's Lair.
Oh my god.
With the suit of armor!
And get your power-washing game on when the Shrek Special Pack DLC makes a splash on the Nintendo Switch system this fall.
Hi, I'm Sam.
And I'm Toby.
Our team has been working on a new game called Morsels.
Morsels?
He plays a mouse fighting against the forces of wicked cats.
I don't like that.
Using magical cards to transform into a bunch of weird little monsters.
Some funny ones.
Tell me.
Can we get like a lo-fi version of that song?
And then like a...
The cat is a monster!
There's a cat in the background!
Oh my gosh!
Sweet baby!
Oh my god!
Hello!
I want to pet him.
It's my cat!
Please enjoy the first-ever trailer for our strange little game.
I like strange little games.
Oh, I miss my cat so much.
Oh gosh.
That's a mouse?
Oh!
Oh cute.
Oh god.
The mouse is feeling things.
The mouse became... a chicken?
What the hell is this?
Oh.
Where's the cats?
They said that there were cats in this game!
Oh my god.
You can...
Oh!
Matara!
She's in every game apparently.
Oh!
Winsil is butchering.
They're like Pokemon.
What is happening?
Oh!
You should have played FNAF Into the Pit.
You'd be a genius at that game then.
Whoa!
Why is...
What is...
What is happening?
This game is an absolute fever dream.
Why?
It's so gross.
Oh my god.
Wow.
I'm gonna cry.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
That was...
That was a weird little game.
You're right.
Oh!
Ooh.
Oh I thought this was a honey pot.
That's right.
Household objects, appliances, and even concepts turn into eligible love interests in Date Everything.
What?
Yes it is.
Oh my god, this game is so quirky!
What is happening?
Why are they all... Why are they all wearing short shorts?
Textbox-chan!
You can date the dialogue box!
This game is quirky quirky.
Oh, they're all voiced too!
I'm not dating my cat!
Oh, he's a clock.
Okay, nevermind.
Find the object of your affection when Date Everything launches on Nintendo Switch October 24th.
Date Everything.
I like the idea.
I like the idea of it, I think.
Hi, I'm Sienna, the lead artist on Peglin.
And I'm Dylan, the game designer of Peglin and the founder of Unnexious Games.
It's very quirky.
The two of us created the first version of Peglin at a game jam in 2019.
The theme of the jam was fall, and we wanted to create something fun and physics-y.
We ended up creating the first version of Peglin's battle system.
When the pandemic started, working on Peglin became a fun and creative escape.
We made cute places and enemies for our little goblin friends to explore.
We then added two of our friends to help speed up development.
And now four years later, we're a team of seven, and we're excited to bring Peglin to Nintendo Switch.
Peglin.
The dragons have been stealing your gold for as long as you can remember.
It's time to delve into the heart of their lair and exact your revenge with the power of Peg.
In this roguelike Pachito-inspired RPG, you'll aim orbs and hit pegs to deal damage in turn-based battles.
The more pegs you hit, the more devastating the blow you'll deal to your enemies.
Balance your way to victory with a variety of different orbs.
Some can split into multiple copies.
Others will pierce both pegs and enemies.
And some will even heal you for every peg you hit.
Hey.
I have to... wait, I have to peg to... to fight?
Interesting.
Oh, I want to play Peggle so bad right now.
It didn't even hit him!
He's too small to throw those bombs.
Hey, kids.
Thanks so much for the five gifted.
Thank you.
This is already out?
Yeah, they said that I was getting poured in.
Each run presents new opportunities for possible combinations.
It looks so fun, though.
I've never heard of it.
...when Peglin bounces onto Nintendo Switch as a timed console exclusive later today.
Oh!
Oh, timed console exclusive?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, not this shit.
No, no, no, no, not the wobbly island.
No!
Get a job!
Buy a house?
Oh, my gosh.
I don't think I played this game correctly when I played it, because I'm...
What do you mean?
What is all of this?
I've never seen any of this in my afterlife.
Wobbly life!
Wait, wait, wait!
Even the...
Even the narrators are arguing.
Everybody is...
This is...
Even the...
Even the MCs are arguing together.
Oh my gosh.
No, Pico Park 2!
Pico Park 2!
I thought it was gonna be TLC or something.
Oh my god, no.
No, that's me!
Oh my god.
Feels like this would be a good game for you, Doki and Matata.
Yeah, friendships will be put to the test!
Today!
Oh my god.
This is what...
This is what we...
We lost...
We lost Tomodachi life to this.
Oh, Shovel Knight.
Woah!
Europe?
Wait, did they say all this was releasing today?
Wow.
I haven't played that, but I always thought it looked so cute.
Damn.
Woah!
Okay.
What's going on here?
Metal Slug Tactics.
Oh, it said available fall 2024.
Okay, so not everything is available today.
I think I'm just...
What is this?
Oh wait, no, I've heard... I remember this actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I do remember.
I remember.
This game.
Sorry, I keep yawning.
Oh my gosh.
That's all for today's show...
Hey, where'd you get that pizza?
I found it in that tower over there.
Pizza Tower!
Pizza Mansion.
I've been wanting to play this actually.
Should've just put it on my schedule.
Pizza!
Pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza.
Pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza.
Pizza, pizza!
Scary pizza!
This game looks so awesome.
Mouse!
Oh my god.
It just like scratches a good itch, you know?
Yay!
Nice.
Live pizza reaction.
That's all for today's Indie World!
Okay, Indies!
We hope you enjoyed today's showcase!
Thank you, Indies!
As always, a big thank you to our Indie community and partners.
Now we still have the partners going on, so hang tight everybody!
Follow our official Indie World account to stay up to date on all things Indie on the Nintendo Switch system!
Not one though, but two!
Time for the showcase!
Yippee!
Happy gaming!
Thank you!
Alright guys, Silksong...
They would save it for the end, you think?
They would save it for the end!
They would save it for the end, right?
They would save it for the end, probably.
Hello everyone!
Welcome to today's Nintendo Direct Partners Showcase!
Partners Showcase!
In this presentation, we'll be focusing on Nintendo Switch games launching in the second half of 2024...
Nerdy laundry!
Thanks for the five gifters!
Okay, let's get into the headlines!
Nintendo...
These games are falling into place!
Tetris...
That's my daughter, Krishna.
She's such an old schoolgirl!
But...
I want to villager!
I want a villager!!
There's a world of weak-willed girls inside my micro dress...
We need to find a way to bring them down.
That's what I gotta do!
Wow!
There's a lot.
What's that?
Oh, cool!
Oh my gosh!
That looks really fun.
If I were good at Tetris, I'd be like, yeah!
Your eyelids are getting heavy.
Follow the watch.
Stop!
A new version of Tetris is coming to Nintendo Switch Online this winter.
And be on the lookout for a Tetris 99 Maximus Cup event.
Also coming this winter.
Tetris 99.
Speed into the unknown.
That's what I say to my cat.
When I'm trying to make him tired, I'll be like, your eyelids are getting heavy.
You're getting sleepy.
You want to go to dreamland.
You'll venture through a massive alien world to reunite with your beloved.
My beloved?
Ride the stylish hoverboard to explore stunning landscapes filled with all sorts of alien structures.
From scorching sands to wavy waters, each area will challenge your traversal skills.
Along the way, you'll face enemies in frenetic melee combat.
By unlocking skills and combining different abilities, you can find more creative ways to overcome foes.
You can also customize the hoverboard to match your riding style.
Solve puzzles and gather resources to boost its speed, steering, gravity, and more.
Whether you're racing through terrain at high speeds or in the thrones of combat.
The hoverboard will be there to help you.
Weep no stone unturned.
As you explore every corner of this vast planet.
You never know what or who you'll find.
Star overdrive.
Launches as a timed exclusive on Nintendo Switch next year.
Do whatever floats your goat.
Welcome to the vast island of San Angora.
Where you'll tip on the world.
A goat.
You're not kidding.
In this sprawling sandbox adventure, you'll headbutt, lick, and explode your way across the island.
Reek havoc on anything and everything you find.
You'll drift around town, join a yoga class, antagonize the locals.
You can do all of that and more.
Complete quests and gain karma to progress the story and unlock customization options.
Karma...?
What is ha-?
Wait... what?
There's a story and goat simulator?
From fashionable nonsense, like floral shirts and inflatable tubes...
to goat variants.
That's not a goat.
Oh sorry it is.
I'm so sorry it said Angry Goat.
I'm so sorry.
Thought it was a goat...
And you're not the only belligerent billy around here.
Unleash all sorts of things.
Goat!
Oh, I can't wait to play with Goat!
Oh, Goat!
Oh no!
Today!
Oh my gosh!
Nice!
Physical Goat!
Game updates?
Star Wars!
Call of Duty Stalker!
Just kidding.
Worms!
Worms?
Oh no!
Disney game!
Oh my god!
Jack Skellington is right there!
Make Bikini Bottom your playground!
What is?
What?
Oh my gosh!
Patrick!
Is this SpongeBob?
No, this is Patrick!
This is Patrick!
The silly sea star from SpongeBob SquarePants stars in this...
Wait, actually!
Sandbox adventure!
It's a sandbox!
Bikini Bottom is your oyster!
Why?
Make some hilarious mayhem by performing whimsical skydives...
Whim?
Oh my gosh!
Digging up treasure in the dump...
Or even blowing off steam in Mrs. Puff's Rage Room!
Oh, that... I was about to say that looks like a Rage Game area.
...to paint tubes...
...to make the world more Patrick-y.
I love Splatoon!
And he's not the only familiar face here.
What?
Okay, where's SpongeBob?
Oh, there he is.
Sandy, Squidward, and more.
Hey,
you turned off the lights!
Step into Patrick's shorts and the inner machinations of his mind.
We're taking off Patrick's shorts?
When SpongeBob SquarePants, the Patrick Star game, launches on Nintendo Switch...
What's happening?
...October 4th.
Pre-orders begin later today on Nintendo Wii Shop.
Who all is pre-ordering the hashtag Patrick Star game?
Ready for your very own personal trainer?
Okay, let's get started.
Hatsune Miku!
Ready?
One, two, jump!
The latest entry in the fitness boxing series is punching its way onto Nintendo Switch.
My personal trainer?
Oh!
Newly added features make it easier to train more regularly.
I can't wait for the art of them.
Choose Quick Workout...
...to jump into an exercise program right after launching the game.
Bring back...
Bring back the Wii Fitness lady.
Let her be an extra character.
Come on.
Bring her back.
With Mitt Drills, you'll practice with your instructor at your own pace.
Bring back Wii Fit Trainer.
And in Sit-Fit Boxing, you can complete exercise programs while seated for a different training experience.
I can just sit and box?
Oh, yeah!
30 brand new songs are included.
Ghostbusters?
There are also six instructors, including two new ones.
Oh my gosh, Ghostbusters!
Plus, you can change their hairstyles.
Oh my god, you can change their hair?
Let them motivate you as you work toward your goals.
She's so cute!
Nice.
Fitness Boxing 3.
Your personal trainer.
Launches on the Nintendo Switch system December 5th.
Ooh, they've been doing a lot of...
Oh!
This is gonna be a match...
They've been doing a lot of the fitness boxing stuff recently.
Eight Capcom fighting games are brawling their way onto Nintendo Switch in one collection.
Here's the complete roster of games.
Cammy.
Capcom versus SNK.
Millennium Fight 2000 Pro.
Capcom versus SNK 2.
Mark of the Millennium 2001.
Project Justice.
Capcom versus SNK.
Just rap, rap, rap, rap, rap, rap, rap, rap.
Whoa!
What is that?
Wait, this is a Guystone!
Oh my god, the training mode.
This is the one we've been talking about.
Oh my god.
Groovy!
Oh, I love stuff like that.
I love seeing the artwork.
Nice!
Oh!
Hugh Jackman.
They're bros.
Power Stone is an actual fun collab game?
No, I wanna see.
Wait, what did he say?
Anime!
Japanese!
Some JRPG?
Atelier already?
I don't think they would make another one so soon, right?
They just... I feel like the mobile game just came out.
Right?
Maybe it is.
I don't know.
They make one every year.
The mobile one doesn't count, but it's...
But it's...
You guys were right!
Atelier Yumiya!
Oh my gosh.
They really did do it.
The newest entry in the Atelier series.
Oh, sorry.
Atelier.
I'm out here on Cultured being like, Atelier?
I'll never forget the Thaisa.
I'll never forget you, Thaisa.
The first two Suikoden games are coming to Nintendo Switch in one bundle.
Meet and befriend up to 108 allies in these turn-based RPGs.
Atelier.
Isn't it French?
Why are you saying it with a French accent?
This collection adds new support features, like the ability to speed up combat, and automate battles with a single button.
Oh yeah!
Suikoden 1 and 2 HD remaster, Gate Rune and Dunon Unification Wars.
Those are some quality of life-changers that are...
That are way from me.
Oh, nice!
After gathering your companions and selecting their vocations, you can now customize their appearance, voice, and more.
With the new Monster Revenant vocation, I want an aggressive voice.
you can use monster-like abilities to fight enemies and heal allies.
There may also be places where you can put monsters to use.
But that's for another time.
Dragon Quest 3 HD 2D Remake ventures onto Nintendo Switch November 14th.
Pre-orders begin later today on Nintendo Wii Shop.
Oh no!
Three Castlevania games originally released on the Nintendo DS system.
Dawn of Sorrow, Portrait of Ruin, and Order of Ecclesia rise again in a single collection.
Arcade classic Haunted Castle is also included.
Featuring the original and a reimagined version.
Plus, there's a gallery for music skills and a music player.
Castlevania Dominus Collection launches on the Nintendo Switch system later today.
Yippee!
Build something you believe in.
Minecraft.
The award-winning strategy series with Sid Meier's Civilization VII.
Who was one of many legendary historical figures including newly added figures such as Queen Himiko.
Friendship is her strength and she can initiate diplomatic endeavors that help you research new technologies.
I'm kind of tired where everything is funny.
And conquer or cooperate with rival civilizations.
You can even create your own path through history by choosing different civs with each new age.
I'm gonna make Benjamin Franklin lose his mind even more.
I'm gonna make him become...
I'm gonna make it so that Benjamin Franklin was Jack the Ripper.
That's how I'm rewriting history.
Can you create an empire on a page on a revolutionary new chapter when Sid Meier's Civilization VII launches on the Nintendo Switch system February 11th.
It's gonna be it.
What's gonna happen.
Forge Bond's transcending time.
Celebrate the 30th anniversary of the Tales of series with a remaster of the action RPG Tales of Grace's F.
Holy moly.
Thank god.
Oh Tales games.
I could never get into them.
Meet Sophie as children.
We will always be friends.
Aww Sophie's really cute though.
Maybe I should get into them.
Several years have since passed.
With their strong friendship and desire to protect their loved ones the now grown up trio get entangled in a conflict that will determine the fate of the world.
This remaster adds enhancements like destination icons and toggling enemy encounters as well as downloadable content from the original game.
Dead outfit.
I am peaked.
I am intrigued.
My interest has been peaked.
I love quality of life stuff like this when they you know when they remaster a game.
Two adorable adventures one cozy bundle.
This is my sims.
This is the sims.
What?
Scabadoo.
Scabadao.
Blaiboo.
Dooseff.
That's so Dooseff.
Close enough.
Welcome back Tomodachi Life 2.
Everybody we did it.
Close enough.
Tomodachi Life 2 has happened.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody.
We did it reddit.
Yes we did it reddit.
Thank you everybody.
Look we are all laughing together even.
What do you mean you just said yay?
You are a sims.
You don't know how to say that word.
More help is wanted.
Oh no.
Think you got what it takes to manage this perilous pizzeria?
Test your skills and your nerves in this first person horror game.
What is this music?
Freddy Fazbear's Pizzeria.
Is this not supposed to be a horror game?
Such as helping performers prep for a show.
Why is the music so funky?
Getting high scores by playing nostalgic arcade minigames.
I don't think we'll ever be free of Five Nights at Freddy's you guys.
I don't think we'll ever be free of FNAF.
But you'll be doing all of this while avoiding animatronic atrocities along the way.
Music man.
Become a Fazbear entertainment superstar.
In Five Nights at Freddy's help one and two.
This music is literally penis music.
It's taking me out.
If you're looking for more adventures in the mega pizza flex.
Find your friend and escape the ruins in this free story DLC for Five Nights at Freddy's Security Breach launching on Nintendo Switch this holiday.
It's pee pee music.
You guys never heard of that?
Let's check out some Nintendo Switch games launching in time for the holidays.
Just look it up.
I promise.
I promise it's a real thing.
Just Dance.
Lego.
Mickey Mouse.
The mouse is loose.
I know I would have eaten that up as a kid though.
Oh this is that Hobbit game.
Yeah.
I remember when they introduced this too.
Just Dance.
Those are real people.
That drives me insane.
Those aren't like they actually dress them up.
Funko fusion?
Oh that's that one Funko game that they did before too.
Yeah.
I do remember that now.
Oh gosh.
Funko pops are indie you guys.
Oh wait sorry.
This is the partner showcase.
Just kidding.
I forgot.
Lego Horizon.
This isn't new either.
Anime.
I should ask the same of you.
Hi.
Aaaaahhhh.
Welcome to the eastern nation of Azuma.
After a calamity struck What's this?
Oh.
Rune Factory.
The only thing I know about Rune Factory is when you have Rune Factory 4 on your 3DS and you know when you hover over it and it makes like a sound.
She goes Rune Factory 4!
That's the only thing I know about Rune Factory.
Literally that specific thing.
Rune Factory 4!
I'm gonna do that.
Oh yeah, I'm gonna mine.
Gosh, leave me alone.
I just wanna be...
Why are you attacking those little small guys?
They're so cute!
Don't hurt the frogs!
Who is that?
Who is she?
Shut up.
Oh my god, I got lightheaded.
Who is she?
Oh.
Wait, this is the last announcement!
Wait, I can't look!
Spoilers!
I can't look!
Can't look.
Yakuza on Switch?
I can't look.
Oh.
Can't look?
Street ruffians.
I was hoping that the last announcement would be like a new game, you know?
Not like a port to the Switch.
But, you know.
So take a break from brawling every once in a while.
Oh!
Pretty cool!
Yakuza Kiwami!
That's interesting.
Wait, are the other Yakuza games on the Switch?
No?
It's so interesting that they're starting with Kiwami though.
My Yakuza brain rot is going wild.
I just screamed in the middle of work.
Oh, Kiwami is the first one?
Oh!
Okay, sorry.
I thought it was... not the first one.
Okay, just kidding then.
I'm silly.
I was thinking of... Oh, I was thinking of Zero.
That's why.
I was thinking of Zero.
Yay!
Thank you for watching!
I'm gonna go to sleep, you guys.
What am I playing tomorrow?
Um...
Oh!
Unmetal.
That was fun.
Um...
No Silksong.
Sorry guys.
Sorry everybody.
Um...
Sorry for your loss.
Good night, Minta.
Good night, everybody.
Um...
Silksong next year, Copium.
I'll be there right next to you with my Tomodachi Life 2, baby!
No matter what kind of direct it is, I'll be labeling it as Tomodachi Life 2, please!
Yes, yes, yes!
Yup, yup, yup!
That's what I'll do!
Verily, thank you so much!
Thanks for the watch-along.
Will you be streaming the Power Wash Shrek DLC Day 1?
Um...
When did it say that it comes out?
Wait, hold on.
Shrek...
DLC...
Power Wash...
Oh...
When does it come out?
Did it say?
Shrek DLC...
Ah!
You must have missed it!
I only made it to your streams because I just got it from work.
So what did I miss?
You missed everything.
Eternal Darkness meant, don't forget.
Eternal Darkness...
I'm not home!
I can't play Eternal Darkness!
I do not have...
I do not have my PlayStation with me.
I am on a laptop.
I think you need to check your sanity meter.
Then go home.
Oh, okay.
Atelier Yumiya looks fun.
I could play Yakuza tomorrow.
I could.
Because I have my Switch.
Anything that was like...
Anything that was announced for the Switch now, I could play.
Because I brought my Switch.
I could stream anything on the Switch.
But no, I'm not gonna do Yakuza just yet.
Sorry guys.
Hold out for Ace Combat.
Hold out for Yakuza.
Eventually.
I will stream them.
Don't worry.
What's a Balatroin?
Is it Poker?
How do you play it?
Because I'm not good at Poker.
Poker is a roguelike.
That sounds so scary.
It's Poker but fun.
It's not Poker.
Roguelike Poker game.
I really like Blackjack.
I'm good at that game.
All I ask is for the next console's gimmick is to have a mic so we can play DS games like Fossil Fighter.
What's that?
I want a mic so that we can play games like...
The ones where you have to dub...
What was it?
WarioWare?
Stuff like that.
Where we have to blow into the mic to do stuff.
That kind of gimmick is so fun.
You don't actually have to know much about Poker.
It's basically Poker 2.
Roguelike Boogaloo.
Oh.
Ace Combat just finished the final edition on AC4.
With S rank.
Like Ace Attorney just to yell objection.
Yes!
Yes, just to yell objection!
Oh my gosh, I forgot you could use to do that.
What is Fossil Fighter?
Oh, sorry.
That was my mic.
Fossil Fighter.
We are...
I do know this game.
Yes, yes.
Sorry, it's hard for me to think of anything right now.
I thought you were insulting me.
I thought you were like, we are...
Calling me a Fossil Fighter.
Keep fighting, Minto.
You Fossil Fighter.
JP Direct has...
Tokimeki Memorial...
Wait, what?
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on.
Hold.
Tokimek...
Tokimemo Remake?
Hold on.
No way.
Where is the Nihongo version?
Hold on.
One moment, please.
I need to stream to it.
Oh, here we go.
I'm looking for...
Pico Park 2.
I can't believe we're getting Pico Park 2.
I cannot believe we're getting Pico Park 2.
I can't believe this is happening.
Oh, wow.
They actually ended it on Rune Factory instead of Yakuza.
That's so interesting.
Hold on.
I'm looking for it.
You know what?
Let's just...
Here.
Let me just put it up on the screen real quick.
Yeah.
One moment.
This is the Japanese Nintendo Direct.
For those wondering.
For those doing timestamps and such.
Of the works.
Okay.
Give me a moment to shrink.
Let's just...
I'm not going to watch the whole thing, obviously.
I'm just going to kind of...
Sift through it a little bit.
Okay.
So, let's turn off the music.
Because they showed us a few things in here as well.
Like, you could see...
The...
This...
The game...
The...
Eight game.
Do not move when it is bright.
Wait.
Actually...
Oh.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
I got jump scared by a child.
Platform 8.
Wait.
No.
I don't think I played this one.
I don't remember that.
Do I play?
I don't know.
You scared me.
I'm sorry.
Do not...
Oh.
This is scary.
Noriba 8.
No.
Oh.
He's supporting a child.
Oops.
I was just thinking.
Oh.
Let's try playing the normal mijn game.
Is recuerd in the chat room Yes.
Wow.
May be a tough task.
What is it called?
Toy defence, children's disposal, I've heard the name of it.
Oh, yeah.
I don't remember.
Please don'tcheck it now.
I've heard, but no tune that I can remember where.
Good useless.
That's cute, the puzzle game.
What is this?
I recognize that narrator voice.
I'm not sure.
Aw.
Hashtag...
Hashtag cool.
Oh my goodness.
See, these are the types of games that you have to play if you want to learn, if you want to get good at Japanese.
Oh my god, it's all like their social media style.
This is crazy.
Holy moly.
Okay, let's keep going.
Oh, what's this?
Pizza tower.
No way!
Wait, oh gosh, hold on, it's cut off on my screen.
Oh.
Ooh.
See, why can't we get this?
.
I wanna play this!
Why everything is about this SNS?
Whoa!
Scary!
.
I want to play this!
Oh my gosh, stop.
It's so cute.
Yurei!
That's me!
Wow, scary!
This looks so awesome.
I love Toshidensetsu.
Aww.
Interesting.
Okay.
I don't need to see Pico Park again, right?
Let's see.
This is...
That... This is Disney game?
Capcom game?
What is this?
Oh wait, is this the Wobbly World game?
Oh, no.
What the hell is this?
What is this?
It's...
It's Animal...
Tetris.
Wait, no.
Why didn't you put the rhino head down?
Oh, no!
It's...
Oh my god, no.
I need to play this.
This is a VTuber game for sure.
I will be... I will be partaking.
Oh, it's available right after the stream.
So it's available now.
Okay, I'll go get a...
a...
a Nintendo card.
What is this?
Hmm?
It's a little slow.
Shiden?
I am unfamiliar.
Where is...
There's an Edgeworth.
Oh!
Kill the crows.
Oh, what's this?
It doesn't matter.
The first Tokimeki Memorial has appeared on the Nintendo Switch.
Do you know the legend of this school?
If you confess to a girl under that tree, you will be in a happy relationship forever.
you will be in a happy relationship forever.
If you confess to a girl under that tree, This is an alligator game?
No!
This is an alligator game?
The game is called Fuji -Saki Shiori.
Fuji-Saki Shiori!
Fuji -Saki Shiori!
Oh my God!
Why couldn't we have this, too!
No.
No go back.
No, go back.
No, no, no, go back.
No.
Ah, Konami-kun.
Konami-kun.
Go back.
Oh my god.
Please come to...
English!
You guys.
Snake could be in there.
It's a Konami game.
Snake could be in the game.
I have to play it.
I'll play it anyway regardless.
What's this one?
Stray Children?
Oh wait, I think I missed the Stray Children.
No!
Oh.
Doraemon!
Oh my god, you run the whole story?
No, thank you.
Well, these...
Why do people just want to work?
Working simulators are so funny.
You just want to work.
Okay.
All right.
It's midnight for me, you guys.
So...
Now...
I go to sleep.
Tokimeki Roborio was worth waiting for though.
It was worth seeing.
Yeah.
I could barely keep my eyes open though.
Okay.
Ateminta everybody!
Thanks for watching with me.
I'll do this again for the next direct.
So...
Hold on...
To your...
To your pantaloons.
Maybe...
Okey dokey.
I'm gonna go to sleep.
Ateminta.
Thank you guys.
If I see you for Unmetal, then I'll see you there.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
Have a good night or day or...
Whatever time it is.
Forever.
Thanks for watching.
I love you.
Thank you.
Goodnight!